the starch in a tote you ate this
morning is broken down into simple
sugars like glucose a six-carbon sugar
that serves as an energy source the
excess glucose in the digestive tract is
stored as glycogen in the liver and
muscle cells for later use it passes
through the digestive tract where the
small intestines absorb glucose from the
bloodstream by facilitated diffusion
insulin and glucagon regulate blood
glucose to antagonistic hormones and
increase the blood glucose level
stimulates pancreatic beta-cells to
increase insulin production into the
bloodstream in target cells for insulin
their receptor tyrosine kinase is
embedded in the cell membrane insulin
binds to rtk which activates the
receptor be of autophosphorylation the
receptor foss relates irs-1 the first
intracellular messenger irs1 binds to
pi3k that pi3k converts pip2 to pip3
when pip3 is charged pkb binds to P ip3
costs related by pdk1 pkp phosphorylates
gsk3 it inhibits the conversion of
glucose to glycogen pkb triggers the
rise of glute for protein to the plasma
membrane med signaling intracellular
storage vesicles to fuse with the plasma
membrane up taking glucose exercises the
best stimulus to increase skeletal
muscle group for expression which
improves a glucose disposal enhance
muscle glycogen storage following
exercise therefore the insulin and
contraction regulated glue for is proven
to uptake glucose and transported during
exercise when blood glucose levels well
below normal pancreatic alpha cells
secrete glucagon into the blood
stimulating the liver to release glucose
epinephrine and glucagon cannibalized
glycogen to glucose they bind to
receptors and muscle liver cells
g-protein signaling activates adenylate
cyclase forming cimp the high cmp levels
activate protein kinase a which
activates phosphorylase kinase and
activist glycogen phosphorylase glycogen
phosphorylase catalyzes the reaction
between an inorganic phosphate glycogen
which lisa glucose 1-phosphate to be
produced which releases glucose from
package type 1 diabetes is an autoimmune
disorder that appears in most children
resulting in beta cells in the liver
being destroyed type 2 diabetes is the
most common form it is the inability of
body cells to respond to insulin
increasing with age people with diabetes
are twice as likely to have a heart
attack or stroke and forty percent more
likely to suffer from quick coma than
people who don't have diabetes for more
information about the six GPB and other
proteins be sure to check out the
protein database website thank you